the senate is up for grabs and it's
going to come down to georgia
two senate races in georgia david perdue
and kelly loffler
two republicans they're running against
really bad hombres well jon ossoff
john ossoff is that democrat who lost a
congressional seat and hollywood poured
a ton of money into him they made him a
big deal he was like beto
1.0 and then he lost and then what do
you do and as a democrat you fail up so
then he runs for senate
he loses again but then they find some
votes and so now there's going to be a
runoff
john ossoff is just kind of a joke and
hopefully he loses
but there's another guy running who's
who's like a really bad guy
his name is rafael warnock he's running
against kelly laufler
kelly loffler was weakened a little bit
in her senate race because there were
some accusations of
some financial problems or whatever it
was all kind of murky but anyway
it weakened her a little bit in the race
raphael warnock
is a pastor i take it of some
denomination
and he's a real radical this guy
said just a few years ago in 2016 that
america needs to
repent for its worship of whiteness no
matter what happens next month more than
a third of the nation that would go
along with this
is reason to be afraid america needs to
repent
for its worship of whiteness
on full display
this season how is it
that you can insult everybody
called muslims
something other than children of god
call mexicans
murderers and rapists insult the
disabled
how is it you can insult everybody but
then one weekend somebody discovers in
the recording that you insult those
whose daughters and wives
look like those who have been supporting
you and then all of a sudden we can't
take it anymore
i gotta repent for the worship of
whiteness
the worship of whiteness so what he's
talking about there is donald trump he
says trump
is you know he's a white basically he's
implying he's a white supremacist or
white identitarian of some sort
and he's insulting all people of other
races which is obviously not true
because donald trump outperformed mitt
romney
in 2016 among black and latino voters
but but moreover
he increased his support among black and
latino voters
substantially in 2020
from all the numbers that we have out
from the 2020 election i know it's still
being counted
all the numbers we have out he gained in
support among black
voters among latino voters among every
among
black women among whatever every single
group you want to look at
other than white men the one group he
lost support in
was white men everyone else he went up
so totally knocks down his promise also
the idea that america worships whiteness
is preposterous the only thing we ever
talk about in this country is how racist
and terrible america
is we only have one racially
discriminatory system of laws in this
country
it's called affirmative action it
disadvantages white and asian applicants
i don't know why the asians got lumped
in but it disadvantages white and asian
applicants
to college and and employment and it
gives an advantage to black and hispanic
and other applicants
it's not the worship of whiteness
all we ever talk about white supremacy
the worst most terrible problem
if you look pew research did an analysis
of racial consciousness in the country
every racial group has higher than 50
racial consciousness
except for white people they're the only
people that don't and and their racial
consciousness is down at about 15
people who say that their their race is
extraordinarily important to their sense
of identity
either important or very important and
of course ask any white person ask me i
guess
i qualify you know little swarthy but i
think i qualify as a white guy i don't
when someone says are you
what is who are you what are you do i
say i'm
i'm a white guy no that's not it's not
even like in the top 50.
i'm catholic i'm a new yorker i guess
originally no longer a new yorker now
i'm a good old southern boy in tennessee
i'm uh american i'm a conservative i'm
whatever i can go down the list
white guys pretty low on the list but
that would be that would not be true on
average for people
of other races the idea that we worship
was crazy
but what it is is a way in to to attack
america's
founding to attack the idea of america
saying it's rotten to the core
those are alternate universes that we're
living in the one that says america is a
good place it's the most
racially tolerant place ever in the
history of the world basically
and the one that says america's worships
whiteness
now warnock this lunatic this true
lunatic is wrong
we are right we the people who say now
race is not the most important thing in
this country
it's actually a good country it's good
for people of all races
and just calm down and shut up you know
we are correct
that framing is right there can be more
and less correct framings of how we view
the world
but that warnock framing the one that
says america is hopelessly bigoted
that one could win that could win in
georgia and by the way if they win in
georgia if those two races go
all of a sudden democrat and and if joe
biden becomes the president
all of a sudden democrats have control
of the senate that's not a great idea
that's not a good thing at all this guy
also the way
you know he's also a complete lunatic is
he once drove over his wife's foot he
ran over his wife's foot while they were
having an argument
if you try to run over your wife during
an argument you are a lunatic
but this guy's also mainstream in 2013
he delivered the benediction at the
public prayer service
at the second inauguration of barack
obama in march 2019
warnock hosted an interfaith meeting
on climate change at his church i feel
like i want to put quotes around
almost every word in that sentence uh al
gore showed up to that
so this guy is fairly mainstream and
this could throw the senate
if you enjoyed that break from
disinformation historical revision
and screaming about the end of the world
be sure to hit the subscribe button so
you never miss another video